LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to
Google Developers Weekly
for October 21, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the world
of Google Developers on the set
and off.
Last week, millions of
Canadians dreamed about hockey
while celebrating Thanksgiving.
Entrepreneurs globally dreamed
about hockey stick growth,
when revenue takes off
at an exponential rate.
Alex Moore of Baydin joined
Don Dodge in our studio,
explaining how you can grow
through focus user acquisition,
and do it quite
well as a company,
even without seeing the
proverbial hockey stick.
From Seattle, Francesc Campoy
Flores and Brian Dorsey
talk about their
experience with Go
and why Python programmers
should consider the language
Brian also talks about
what surprised him,
giving some thoughts and
recommendations for Pythonistas
interested in learning about Go.
Felipe Hoffa, a regular
mention here on GDL weekly,
invited Aleem Mawani,
the founder of Streak,
to review the latest big
query announcements, and shows
the multiple ways that
Streak leverages data
that they stream into BigQuery.
Now they can instantly
analyze their App Engine logs
for debugging and
performance analysis.
Next, from our New
York City office,
YouTube's Jeff Posnick does more
than tell you about new stuff.
He takes on common
issues developers
face when running YouTube
Analytics API reports,
sharing resources to help
you keep your programs
and statistics running smoothly.
And your websites and mobile
apps have a need for speed.
Our Chrome Team partnered with
The New York Times to help you
tune up performance.
Engineers from the Times,
Forecast I/O, and Google
showed tips to bring smoother
scrolling and animation, faster
load times, and
the app experience
that both you and
your users love.
And if you've heard about the
Wallet Object API Mihai Enescu
is your guide to
getting started.
The first episode in a
new series on this API
displays how you can set up
your Wallet Objects accounts,
including both OS2 Service
Account and Wallet Objects
Issuer Account.
In our next video, the
Enterprise Maps Team
is back with another episode
of What In the World.
This week talks about great
ways to restructure KML data
so it looks great
in Google Earth.
Bonus.
This session also includes a
brief introduction to PyKML.
Rounding out the week
in our GDL studios,
Baydin's Alex Moore is
back for a second show.
Alex tells us how he
found angel investors
in balanced investment, revenue,
user acquisition, and feature
development.
We also get a tip on how to
make limited server capacity
work for you.
On the Android
Developers channel,
it's all fun and games
from our robot overlords.
Get the latest
from Todd Kerpelman
with Game On!, while Bruno
Oliveira talks achievements
and leader boards.
From the land of Appscript
comes news this week
of a connection
with Eclipse IDE.
Using Google
Plug-in for Eclipse,
you can now take advantage of
Eclipse editing, auto-complete,
and management features in your
Appscript projects like a boss.
It's also been an exciting week
for developers in Argentina.
The Developer Bus is
a Google reality show
in which start-up
developers work on apps
live as you and the world watch.
Check it out at
developerbus.withgoogle.com.
And to make sure that you
never miss a single thing from
the world of Google developers,
subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube and check
out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.